je trouve que c'est un juste retour des
choses que des caisses populaires se
désintéresse de la scène électorale est
de plus en plus met donc voilà alors
évidemment il y aura des unis peut y
avoir une attente autoritaire dans
certains segments des classes populaires
oui je pense que dans une certaine
paysannerie ou dans un monde agricole
traditionnellement ou 19e
les forces conservatrices et le parti de
l'ordre pouvait s'appuyer sur le gros du
monde agricole dans la mesure où le
monde agricole était plutôt conservateur
il était plutôt réactionnaire il était
aussi sous tutelle de l'église il était
sous tutelle parfois post féodal du duo
nobliaux du coin bon donc ça ne s'en
faisait pas une classe très progressiste
c'est sûr et on retrouve ces éléments la
dent dans les classes populaires manon
la diversité idéologique énorme c'est
pour ça qu'on ne peut jamais attribuer
des traits invariants aux classes
populaires en termes idéologiques en
terme psychologique en termes
esthétiques sas et c'est tout à fait
impossible la demande autoritaire elle
peut aussi se comprendre
venant des classes populaires et l'a
peut-être qu'on serait un peu plus dans
un invariant anthropologique à savoir
que oui
la classe populaire c'est quoi c'est
celle qui est particulièrement exposée à
l'inconfort justement al'inverse donc de
la bourgeoisie qui est dans le confort
et qui globalement à tous les moyens de
pouvoir rester dans le confort classes
populaires sont très exposés exposés au
chômage explose exposé à la déréliction
social exposés aux violences exposés à
l'insécurité tout à fait exposés à une
certaine délinquance qui peut émerger
des classes populaires mais qui peut
surtout se retourner contre les classes
populaires
oui donc à ce titre là la situation d'un
confort maximal qui est celle des
classes populaires et des dominés dans
une société peut faire que mécaniquement
ça entraîne une demande d'autorité une
demande d'ordre
je trouve ça finalement tout à fait
logique et presque légitime en quelque
sorte
après les traductions politiques de ça
c'est là que je pourrais me dissocier
parce qu'au bout du compte les les
classes populaires qui aurait extraire
en demande d'autorité se sont surtout
embrouillés par des petits tyrans qui
leur font croire que la politique leur
politique et servira alors qu'en fait
les tyrans ou pas qu'on s'appelle
erdogan
or ban ou maquereau on est toujours au
service des
mine on est au service de ceux qui ont
l'argent et donc pas du tout service des
classes populaires
[Musique]